♪ ♪
>> I THINK IT'S VERY CLEAR FROM
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT I'VE
SPOKEN TO, THEY DON'T WANT A
LAWLESS KING LIKE PRESIDENT.
I TELL THE PRESIDENT BRING IT,
BECAUSE 10 MILLION PEOPLE SIGNED
A PETITION TO IMPEACH THIS
PRESIDENT.
WHAT PRECEDENT TO A SET WHEN WE
DON'T DO ANYTHING.
>> I THINK IT'S HARD TO NOT SEE
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S COMMENTS
THIS MORNING AS ANYTHING BUT AN
IMPEACHMENT REFERRAL TO THE
CONGRESS.
>> Laura: HOW DOES THE G.O.P.
PLAN TO RESPOND TO THIS NEWLY
UNIFIED FRONT TO IMPEACH?
HERE NOW IS HOUSE MINORITY STEVE
SCALISE FROM NEW ORLEANS, WHAT
IS THE LEADERSHIP'S RESPONSE TO
THE DEMOCRATIC DRUMBEAT THAT
BUILT UP OVER THE LAST FEW WEEKS
BUT YOU REALLY FELT IT TODAY?
>> THIS HAS BEEN THEIR PLAN ALL
ALONG, THEY'VE BEEN PUSHING FOR
IMPEACHMENT SINCE THE DAY THEY
WON THE MAJORITY.
JERRY NADLER WAS BRAGGING ABOUT
IT, YOU'RE SAYING OTHERS SAY
THIS IS WHAT THEY WERE GOING TO
MAKE THEIR TWO YOUR MAJORITY
ABOUT.
IF THIS IS WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ELECTED THEM TO DO, I
THINK THERE WILL BE A HEAVY
PRICE FOR DEMOCRATS TO GO DOWN
THIS PATH.
THEY SPENT TWO YEARS AND OVER
$30 MILLION IN TAXPAYER MONEY
SAYING THERE WAS PROOF OF
OBSTRUCTION, THAT THERE WAS
PROOF OF COLLUSION.
THERE WAS NONE OF IT.
THE ONLY COLLUSION THAT HAPPENED
WERE PEOPLE OFFICIALS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, EVEN IN
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WHO
WERE SPYING ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT HAPPENED, THEY HAD A
PARTISAN AGENDA WITHIN THE FBI
TO TAKE DOWN THIS PRESIDENT
BEFORE HE WAS ELECTED.
PEOPLE AREN'T GOING TO STAND FOR
THIS, IF THEY WANT TO PURSUE
THIS ROAD, IT'S GOING TO BE AT
THE PERIL OF THEIR MAJORITY.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK THE
SENATE INTEL COMMITTEE AS OTHERS
HAVE SAID SHOULD SUBPOENA BOB
MUELLER TO TESTIFY BEFORE THEM?
HE SAYS HE'S NOT TALKING, HE DID
PRONOUNCE THAT TODAY
DEFINITIVELY.
SHOULD REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE
TAKE THAT AS GOSPEL AND SUBPOENA
HIM TO TESTIFY?
>> REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE
HAVE BEEN FOCUSED ON DOING THEIR
JOB, THE JOB THEY WERE ELECTED
TO DO TO KEEP THIS COUNTRY
MOVING FORWARD TO GIVE THE
ECONOMY BACK ON TRACK.
THE DEMOCRATS IN THE HOUSE HAVE
MADE IT CLEAR THEY DON'T CARE
ABOUT THE ECONOMY OR ABOUT THE
CRISIS AT THE BORDER.
THE VERY COMMITTEE THAT HAS
JURISDICTION OVER THE CRISIS AT
THE BORDER THAT IS REAL TODAY,
MORE THAN 4,000 PEOPLE CROSSING
OUR BORDER ILLEGALLY, THAT IS
THE COMMITTEE THAT IS CHAIRED BY
JERRY NADLER THAT IS FOCUSED ON
THIS WITCH HUNT, FOCUSING DOWN
RAT HOLES TO TRY TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT EVEN WHEN THERE IS NO
PROOF OF NO COLLUSION.
>> Laura: I WANT A 52ND
ANSWER, DO THE DEMOCRATS THINK
IMPEACHMENT IS THEIR ONLY CHANCE
OF BEATING TRUMP NOW?
>> NO BUT IT'S THE ONLY WAY THEY
CAN APPEASE THEIR RADICAL LEFT
BASE.
>> Shannon: ALAN LICHTMAN IS
OUT THERE SAYING THAT'S THE ONLY